- All right, everybody,
it's time for a toast,
but you know what?
This can be a normal toast.
It can't be ordinary.
This is a toast to Dwayne
Johnson, shape-shifter, demigod,
savior of the Kelly Clarkson
Show season one premiere.
Hit it, guys!
(upbeat marching band music)
Oh, there's some red cards (indistinct).
Okay, okay.
(Kelly screams)
All right, all right.
Get it, get it, get it, get it.
Oh my, that looks like a workout.
(Kelly laughs)
Oh, God.
Oh!
Oh, we got a crown.
We got a crown.
- Oh, thank you.
- There we go, we've got a crown.
Now, what the hell just happened?
(Kelly laughs)
That was something.
That's a parade that never ends.
(Kelly laughs)
- Kelly, so, before we do,
first of all, I wanna say,
what a beautiful gesture.
Thank you so much for doing this, Kelly.
This was an amazing surprise.
- We love you.
- Thank you.
And now, the world finally knows
what goes through my wife Lauren's head
after we have a sexy date night,
all of that stuff.
(Kelly laughs)
- That's seven from "Friends."
That's amazing.
All right, everybody,
let's raise our glasses,
here's to the man, the myth,
the best guy that's ever been.
(upbeat marching band music)
What are you?
Are you serious?
Oh my God.